all right [ __ ] fantastic
there's that [ __ ] awesome bit in the
90s fantastic four cartoon where the
voice actor for johnny storm
was like
[Music]
this game already looks let's play easy
co-op
there's no co-op you know no it broke it
broke you know it's turned off
then you press start there you go i did
it look by the way i guess this game
like ends whoa it starts with doctor
look it's captain america what the [ __ ]
oh doctor doom looks
great oh man did you see his face all
these
these character models are rad oh [ __ ]
back to cgi my eye oh is that chris
evans yeah that's chris
it's an attempt at chris evans it looks
fine
bruce willis over here
oh look okay here's a secret origin is
when i played this as a little kid with
my friend jordan
i used to throw out these little spider
robots and i used to call them charlie
oh oh that's why you call them yeah
that's the origin this is the first
charlie
dude i i seriously am trying sword i'm
playing the game with one hand
right one eye is attached to the tv and
one eye is attached to my chat
yeah my eyes are pointing both
directions right here
oh my god oh jesus like his eye is like
rolled up into his eye behind his eyelid
now one of them and the other one's
looking the opposite direction
okay focus i can't roll it don't touch
it don't touch it it'll break
horrible circumstances oh dude that he
got knocked to the floor
did he clip to that guy's leg and look
at her big ps2
titties
oh never mind holy [ __ ] even when she's
invisible
they're visible oh god i wonder if she
has jiggle physics
please stop xavier you john cena i don't
know how to answer this
look yeah see
that's funny oh i get it i get the joke
i didn't get it i really didn't
i'm serious i didn't get the joke i
think
i think i got it ah there was a time oh
there's an x-men symbol instead
they're like the other fox franchise you
fool
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh all right sorry i'm
back to reading check guys i'm sorry
i did it well i like how he's all like
you can't see me like this but like
johnny's right there he's like
he could just be like guys he looks like
a giant rock guy but he's fine
he's a little pretty he's a little ugly
he made a comment on how ugly he was as
soon as he walked in the room oh my god
you're
[ __ ] disgusting you're a horrible no
i know why you have to
you were capable of killing yourself you
should oh jesus what the hell knock them
down knock it down and cause a problem
see me just shatter that glass in the
background which is causing mayhem for
no reason
oh look i get to do that dumb thing
again
now quick johnny burn the building so
everyone inside die i'm gonna kill him
if there's no fire escape they can't
escape the fire
you understand johnny we're gonna kill
him
i'm gonna burn this [ __ ] town to the
ground jonathan
holy [ __ ] dude it's not even like we're
fighting dudes you just walk up to these
buildings and you're destroying people
those people are shooting guns at us
because i'm a large rock monster
just tearing down all this problems the
guy who's catching dudes on fire and
throwing them and
would you not ah get on oh my god my
children oh jesus
jenna get out through the back entrance
oh my god make sure
this guy had a bunch of rubble look at
this look how mad i
am josh how many body pillows do you
have like seven
wow is quick all of you yeah they're all
they're all godzilla mendoza sponsored
do we sell those and then merch stuff
we sell medical masks now does anyone
need to catch a kid
chat if you've played this game which
you probably haven't where should we go
quick google a walkthrough you can't no
you can't go
that way it looks like a car with a leg
throw it somewhere else
put the cap down dude
there's probably children inside i will
throw this minivan
full of children cause i'm tired of
scripts where they're like what if
batman killed wouldn't that be
interesting and new and it's like no
it's not
they just clobber that blind lady with a
pipe that was
[ __ ] up i don't care how [ __ ] tough
this
this street crew what am i doing i'm the
thing
why is that cop just sitting there
watching
him just sitting on the fence like you
guys got him looks like my job's done
today
all the [ __ ] npcs are on fire the
citizens running around
on fire just another day in los angeles
yeah just uh yeah there's another day in
the cities
of stuff in the in the service we're all
the human torch at heart
we're all michael b jordan i went to the
big and tall man
store outside of yancey street they were
very accommodating they acted like
they've seen a hundred people like me
this week that's the only place i'm
accepted anymore is the big attorney
you don't know what that's like we have
to punch the fire truck
i'm going to throw this car off the
bridge
i ripped the door off save him and now i
can pull this woman out i thought he was
just gonna throw the shirt
throw the one she gave him a little hug
oh that was cute what do we do with this
why i don't we have to punch the fire
truck oh oh yeah go punch it oh wait no
we don't have to punch it we have to
save it yeah grab it
oh whoa why did it slide so fast
because i bumped it with my my two
massive chests
you're a giant [ __ ]
big hand come saying oh god hey hey reed
well yeah to give me a reach around why
don't ya
which one of us can do the naruto ninja
signs faster
i don't even know that oh it hurts so
bad doing his hands
[Music]
i'm trying to do the thingy come on
sorry sorry stop killing the mole man
that's our that's wait hold on there
there we go
there's our rap album cover what's up
baby the dynamic duo
okay what uh i think we're stuck should
we switch games now
i've played enough of a fantastic show i
don't know how we've been playing this
one so far that's unchromatic friend
or foe friend or fiender oh
don't think i've ever asked but opinions
on daredevil netflix specifically season
season three xavier
when you get a moment so he was checking
his phone right now
what huh what one hey wait a minute
that's not nick fury
that's dick nury big deary that's the
ripoff one big mitchum oh i don't like
this game
who is the most powerful avenger in your
opinion which i don't know
which avenger which one scarlet witch
can like
rewrite reality there we go we got
superman he's wearing the red trunks i'm
gonna settle the trunks argument right
now
okay batman doesn't need it as bad
because he's got black
gloves and that kind of helps break up
the colors and add something to the
middle section of his suit
he needs the [ __ ] trunks or he looks
stupid i can get it i get it yes they're
silly
all right yes underwear on the outside
ha ha jokes all right whatever
he looks dumb without them okay he looks
worse without them than he does with
them
all right shut up everyone how do i pick
this up i want to commit
super crimes this feels
jank whoa boy is it pilot controls
yeah i don't like the inverted y can i
switch that
look i'm man of steel superman i'm
killing
people don't worry lois i'll stop the
meteors with my face
oh my glasses i need those two no i
can't be clark kent everyone will know
my identity
i need those to appear unremarkable
look it's oh it's kevin spacey yo
oh no he was that who was that
why did oh god luther freed on appeal oh
that happened too
oh look that superman statue has the
trunks
they're they're right there in the right
they did it right it's
the supernova okay the man of steel
costume was designed with trunks in mind
like it has it in all of the concept art
and they took it out at the last minute
that's why it looks dumb oh jesus that
was
something
[Music]
it's like it's like the game's trying to
like whoa
look doofy as [ __ ] that's so doofy
xavier whose side are you on for kong vs
gorilla
you mean godzilla
i did i actually messed that up versus
gorilla
kong versus the mirror no
it's kong versus like a normal gorilla
normal [ __ ] looking dude yeah look at
me i'm running around i got a big tank
i'm
[ __ ] oh i'm run i'm walking on
sunshine
did i win no what's he doing
i get it also the objectives aren't fun
bro what the [ __ ] look at this book you
see that throw
do you see that throw yeah and you're
floating one time my friend
uh while i was like watching a movie
decided to come to the living room he
was actually my roommate at the time my
sophomore year
that's disgusting one sec just the [ __ ]
outside i'm sorry
just don't don't pick it up stop trying
to pick it up i there's no way to do
damage you have to walk behind buildings
or something
first obviously okay i'll wait here yeah
and then they all just
blame it whatever superman
[ __ ] christ get behind a thing like
you did half a second ago
why you're just running into a wall and
then asking why you're running into a
wall
keep going what there's this kind of way
there though i didn't i was literally in
the middle of throwing it xavier all i
have to say is that this game is good
and you're it's your fault
it's just me it's clearly it's me it's
not me it's not me it's you it's you
it's me
yeah it looks so goofy
okay i gotta start doing that whoa whoa
whoa
i just actually gave him a little bit of
a hug please let me beat up the mongol
oh i'm gonna do the cool speed move and
then bam i'm gonna punch him ready
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] never mind he's fine
he's fine
come on fairy look it's kevin spacey
getting all up in this ice cave
i have bloodborne look it's the bad guy
from [ __ ]
from call of duty advanced warfare yeah
i remember him he
he uh had to get he had the game fuel
sponsorship and the doritos you remember
that you
remember the game remember when he did
that scary youtube video
oh sure they may have tried to separate
us but what we have is too strong it's
too powerful
i mean after all we shared everything
you and i
i told you my deepest darkest secrets
and then lex luthor is like i don't know
why superman is
has this hate campaign against me i have
no recollection of
that laser but but i choose to live my
life now as a gay man
i don't remember building that laser
it's there
i didn't do it like this i didn't make
it it's on the top of my building
superman's [ __ ]
looking at twitter going god damn it he
pulled that card i'll never beat him
metallo has escaped no i didn't i kicked
his ass
look he's just fist pumping over these
like people like dying
yeah i hope this superman is like yeah i
beat my tallow
i defeated them with some words where's
the ambulance
but it's definitely not impossible by
any
can i just drop her okay do it i'm
trying my damn shoes
it won't oh i set her down what the [ __ ]
this was throwing yeah i don't want
venom to be harry osborne i'm
tired of that it's happened once and i'm
tired of it just like just go straight
down
holy [ __ ] that was really fun there was
a guy at your feet
what if he just look it's like this is
like a simulator for like what if
cyclops just didn't have the visor one
day
gene um can you help me see i can't see
he's killed everyone in the [ __ ]
house where the [ __ ] is it oh my god
oh man stop turning your head
[Music]
you